your body and mind are so inextricably
linked as to be inseparable
this means that training the body is
also training the mind
and vice versa it could be argued that
movement and learning to move is the
primary function of the human brain
while learning about ancient history is
a mentally taxing process
it's nowhere near as multi-sensory or
rich in information as learning to move
the body
this requires not only knowledge of the
intended movement but also information
from every single sense
and as much of the body as possible
movement begins in the brain before you
can move you first need to enact that
movement in the brain in order to refine
it
the intention to move begins in the
posterior parietal cortex
an area that has been linked with the
concept of free will the basal ganglia
provides you with action selection to
choose that movement
we then refer to the cerebellum the
little brain named by leonardo da vinci
in order to incorporate information from
our surroundings
this includes detailed proprioceptive
feedback from the sensors in our muscles
tendons and fascia that provide us with
a detailed picture of the current
position of our body
and its balance the pre-motor cortex
combines this information
with a detailed concept of physics
learned from countless interactions with
the world
to help position us in space and refine
the movement further
the motor cortex then lights up with a
pattern that directly corresponds to
that movement
letting us curl the weight or throw that
punch during all this the brain
essentially predicts what the movement
will look like
if the finalized movement lines up with
that prediction the neural patterns that
we use to strengthen via reinforcing
neurochemicals
again a lot of this takes place in the
cerebellum which is essentially a
learning and prediction
machine if the movement is wrong and
there's a prediction error
then the movement is refined next time
this neural plasticity allows us to
learn new skills and movements and to
continuously adapt to our environments
and this is why learning entirely new
skills such as dance choreography or
martial arts
is fantastic for increasing neural
plasticity the very process of learning
presents a swathe of plasticity
promoting chemicals that can then be
used to further support learning in
other areas
i don't know if there's any evidence to
support this but theoretically you might
find that learning a new martial art
could help you to learn a new language
and even vice versa heck it might even
help you to bench more
edo portal the movement guru is someone
i'll talk about more on this channel in
future
his philosophy is to train movements
rather than muscles and he is one of the
most
prominent figures in the new movement
training
uh movement edo believes that the
acquisition of new skill goes through
multiple stages
starting off very difficult before going
through a period of refinement
and eventually mastery edo believes that
we should spend more time in the first
and second stages
this is where the most learning is
occurring and as such the biggest
benefits to our plasticity
and cognitive development so many of us
focus on mastering movements on adding a
few kilos to a lift that we're already
very proficient at far more
transformative is to learn something
entirely new
constantly
research conducted by tracy and ross
alloway shows that activities such as
climbing trees crawling on beams and
running barefoot
are powerful tools for enhancing working
memory these coincidentally
are the kinds of activities we would
naturally engage in as children
alloway also suggests that activities
such as surfing might be perfect for
this kind of thing
what if you don't move what if you only
picture moving in that scenario we still
see very similar activity in the brain
this means that we can actually rehearse
movements in our mind's eye and
strengthen the very same neural pathways
if you visualize throwing a ball you
will actually use the precise same
neural networks
and you can strengthen those connections
in just the same way making the movement
more efficient and precise without even
moving
and what's strangest about this of all
is that this very process of being able
to move without moving
might underpin the very nature of our
cognition
[Music]
this is the hypothesis put forwards by
embodied cognition
and specifically the idea of embodied
semantics as you listen to this
you're translating everything i say into
pure meaning you've learned english
what was your basis of reference when
learning that if english is the
programming language
then what is the machine code of the
brain embodied semantics is a school of
thought which is just a theory mind you
that suggests that the basis for thought
is movement and first-hand experience
when i tell you about an experience that
i had walking through cold woods you
understand this by activating brain
regions that correspond with that
experience
in other words you recall the sensation
of walking through the woods
you feel your legs move slightly you
feel and hear the crunching of twigs
underfoot
and you remember what emotions this
conjured up for you in the past
without a body and without direct
experience you'd have no way of
understanding the concept of walking
through the woods
we see this when we try to translate
something to a stranger we do so by
mimicking and aping the actions we're
trying to describe
or by desperately pointing at things
that could provide a shared reference
point
and likewise this helps to explain to
some extent why memories can trigger
vivid emotional reactions as
though they were real and even where we
gesticulate and mimic as we speak
it explains how thoughts can occur
without language
it's not visualization as such and it's
not just kinesthetic experience either
rather it's a multi-sensory experience
created in your mind's eye
or your visuospatial scratch pad to use
the correct terminology
we even see this in the way that
language developed see daniel
l everett's sign progression theory of
language and the excellent video on the
topic over at what i've learned
this is the seat of your working memory
your ability to hold on to sensory
information and concepts
and thus your ability to imagine to
extrapolate and to predict
the prefrontal cortex which evolved much
later than the hindbrain that houses the
cerebellum
is where our ability to engage in
abstract thought occurs but this is
still apparently built on top of our
grounded experience
could you understand and perform maths
without an experience of quantities
this might also explain our proclivity
for metaphors
it also points to a connection between
the working memory and the movement of
the body
this might help us to understand how
something like a bear crawl along a tree
branch
could possibly result in greater math
skills and it explains why the
cerebellum
features connections that reach deeply
into the prefrontal cortex
it explains why more and more studies
are demonstrating a role for the
cerebellum
and the pre-motor cortex in seemingly
unrelated cognitive tasks
because these functions underpin our
ability to think abstractly
in one study it was even found that
wrestlers would use their motor regions
more than average people
when performing cognitive tasks such as
mentally rotating objects
most people relied more on their visual
cortex but it turned out that using
their bodies was actually more effective
for the wrestlers
and this might also explain how
practicing fine motor skills like
cursive can improve skills such as
verbal fluency the aerosmith school uses
cursive drills and tracing exercises
to help children that struggle with
language many of them develop skills
equal to or even superior
to their peers using this method there's
a well-documented link between the
pre-motor cortex and speech production
and careful manipulation may help to
develop the former
this is another takeaway then engage in
some activity that requires
fine precise control of your hands we're
not just talking about exercise here
and again the cerebellum is also a
learning engine it plays a huge role in
refining movement and predicting
outcomes
which may also help to conceive higher
order concepts and predictions
the cerebellum has around 69 billion
neurons
as compared with the 16 billion found in
the cerebral cortex
that's surely worth thinking about this
is why i believe that any attempt to
create a disembodied artificial
intelligence
that is to say an artificial
intelligence with no physical presence
will prove to be unsuccessful a true
general ai would at the very least
require an artificial environment
it may be the co-evolution between
environment and organism
that gives rise to intelligence
this video only scratches the surface of
the deeply complex relationship between
the mind and the body
for instance consider the way that our
physiology can impact on our mindset
and vice versa learning to understand
this reaction allows us to gain greater
self mastery
a topic that is referred to as physical
intelligence by some
or interception then there's the ability
to increase strength and performance by
enhancing the mind muscle connection
or what about the link between intention
and performance
a simple trick like punching through the
bag rather than into it can have a
profound effect on the way we deliver a
strike
i could also talk about how improving
cardio has been shown to increase bdnf
one of those key substances promoting
plasticity in the hippocampus
the primary brain region responsible for
memory exercise also leads to short-term
increase in endorphins that feel good
hormones
and of course improving your
cardiovascular system will also upgrade
the supply of oxygen to the brain
stay tuned as i'll discuss all of this
in future videos but to end i'd just
like to reinforce the importance of
training the mind
as well as the body neuroplasticity
shows us the areas of the brain and the
connections between them can be
developed and strengthened just like any
muscle
more so even so why do we worry about a
legs day without ever considering
a brain day so i hope you found this
video useful and interesting guys let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below
do you notice any cognitive benefits of
training or vice versa
how do you combine them both subscribe
and hit the notification bell if you
want more like this and if you enjoy
this philosophical approach to training
the mind and body for better human
performance
you might enjoy my ebook and training
program super functional training
i go into a lot more detail in that and
provide my most actionable advice and
programming to suit all levels
check it out in the link below there's a
discount on right now as many of us are
still
stuck in lockdown thanks again for
watching this one guys and i'll catch
you next time
bye for now
and by the way guys i made all these 3d
graphics myself so i'd love to know what
you think of them in the comments below
want to see more of them or shall just
stick to what i know